life is consistent with every big movie
like The Hobbit comes a big trailer like
Superman or the Man of Steel as they're
calling it folks - big mommy can make it
small so the new trailer - Man of Steel
has hit the Internet yeah it's
completely worth talking about this is a
Superman movie it's a reboot of the
Superman movies I know reboots get a
really bad rap these days but sometimes
they're really necessary because
Superman Returns came out and sometimes
reboots are necessary so the new Man of
Steel trailer you really don't know that
much more about the movie you know more
about Star Trek in the darkness than you
do Man of Steel now that it's a bad
thing because again like the teaser
trailer this trailer shows a really good
tone for the movie they've humanized
Superman the Superman world is now a
world of conflict and doubt I am
indestructible I'm kal-el of Krypton so
where do I even fit in this world
Jonathan Kent instead of being like son
you were put here for a reason it's all
like you have to keep this side of
yourself a secret what was I supposed to
do just let them die
maybe I find that interesting the rock
in his life isn't like oh yeah you need
to be Superman which makes it more
monumental when he steps up to be
Superman humanizing Superman can make it
a really boring ass movie or a really
cool and relatable Superman movie
I think it'll be that second one I'm
hoping it'll be that sagramonte if it's
not Superman movies are done forever
they're not going to redo another one
not for decades anyway and among all
this humanization and drama and really
cool red flowing capes that look awesome
that I want so I can just wear it in a
mall or something you know you would do
if you had one shows death and
destruction a glimpse of jor-el and it
shows one glimpse of Michael Shannon is
Zod he doesn't have the full beard he
has his goatee thing it doesn't matter
because I just want to see Michael
Shannon as Zod be all I would find it
perfectly adequate if you could go ahead
and kneel before Zod that's all I'm
waiting for really one thing I actually
don't know because I don't look into
movies in depth like movies like this I
want to be surprised but the flipside of
that is it leaves you with questions and
some pictures of this movie I see the S
on Superman's chest his Superman symbol
being a red s on a yellow background
other pictures I see it as a red s on a
black background so does it change
colors at one of those things where it's
only yellow in the sun shining on it
I've seen both in Superman lore so like
oh yeah we can do both this is 2013 this
movies coming out we can do both and
Superman leaves us with one question at
the end he was convinced at the world
wasn't ready
what do you think
I say yes kal-el we are ready for you so
the new dramatic darker tone humanizing
Man of Steel trailer have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more